you know i'm not really concerned about
it i just think i'm just getting older
and i need classes
yeah you know i used to have 20 20
vision really
yeah [ __ ] i guess it's gonna get bad for
me at some point then too
it's bizarre old age hi
even when i wake up now it's like
there's a couple of things that are like
weird about it like what can you tell me
yeah what are the big age things you're
feeling
just this morning i woke up and i was
just like
ow you know not a pain or a sharp
anything
it's just er things are sore now that
normally
aren't sore used to be sore i used to
just jump out of bed and like
come on life let's do this right
in my mind i wouldn't say that out loud
but now it's just like ah oh
okay i'm up you know there's like that
initial like
things that kind of are achy and and and
and i
fee i i don't i feel like a child
you know i you know when people go you
know you'll see like a documentary
you'll see a scientist
you go look at that old scientist and
they're like i'm 46.
and you're like what the [ __ ] old
scientist is 46.
i'm 48 i don't feel or look like that
old scientist you don't you don't
already have that off at all it really
angers me yeah
because i really was hoping that the
13-year age gap between us would make
you look like myopa
no but it it we look like a regular same
aged couple and i hate it yeah
yeah it's like it's it's it's strange
and as you get older you do think about
the end a little bit more often
because if you think more than half my
life is over now
oh if you're basing on a hundred years
oh well then now
most of it's over there [ __ ] you now
most of it
thirds of the way i mean okay i mean
think about it
i have probably at the most
40 more years at the least
20 more years damn why do you look at it
like that but think of it think of
that i don't wanna can we move on no i
don't wanna move on i think this is good
stuff that we should talk about
it does it because it's like you said at
least 20 more years i'm like no anyone
can croak
five minutes from now and then we get
into that conversation and then i'm all
into
in my head and then i'm going to be
anxious and looking at you
and worried about you do you have fears
that i'm not going to wake up one
morning i genuinely
have that is when i comedy
i got
[Laughter]
what is the one question i ask you the
most that pisses you off
um are you okay are you okay yeah yeah i
hate that are you okay
yeah yeah it's like every sound he makes
at night
in bed even the one that i [ __ ]
hate so much i don't play it i wish it
was a fart oh the scratching
nose oh the water smells oh when i sleep
yeah oh my god he just like
i don't know what it is but that's
that's what wakes me up
yeah i'll wake up and she'll i'll just
get a drink of water shoes are you okay
okay can i drink water yeah yeah i need
to get that out of my head
it's it's my my worry no amount of worry
for me is gonna change any outcome so
it's like what's the point of worrying
um but you know like i i get so
angry with him because i just want him
to be healthy and he just really does
not
he's so reckless with his body and it
just pisses me off
yeah i am well does you thinking about
yours
does it make you want to get healthy for
real for real or not really thinking
about your death every day well i did
that i did the hypnotherapist
sunday and um
it was impossible to start yesterday
because i was shooting
you know when i'm on when i'm working
it's on a set especially it's like i
just because of the stress of it i i
it's just it's it goes hand in hand
i think the most difficult thing about
quitting smoking it's so tied into
performing and stuff your process you
know like when you're at like a
night because you know you perform at
night clubs and you're around
i don't drink so people are boozing and
you know having fun and all that stuff
it's just a part of the um also you get
anxious to do two shows a night in
between shows there's some anxiety
not nervousness but it's just like okay
you know
it's a packed room and i gotta do it you
know i have to you know and
it's it's it's just tied into it so we
i also want to talk about you know um i
felt kaleila and i have been watching
alone
do you see the light last season